hi there today we're looking at implicit
neural representations with periodic
activation functions by vincent's it's
Minh Julien NP Martell Alexander W
Bergman David Beale and L and Gordon
wetstein so this paper is a bit of a
special paper if you're like me coming
from like classic machine learning or
deep learning things like this this
paper requires you to think around your
your notion of what it means to handle
data and so on a bit and to think about
data points and so on essentially what
they're doing is they are representing
signals such as images or sound or
generally waves or point clouds they're
representing these signals as functions
mapping for example from their
coordinates to their values and we'll
see what that entails and they they're
not the first ones to do this but they
managed to do this very well using these
new models called sirens which are
basically neural networks that so siren
spelled like this neural networks that
have sine waves as their nonlinearities
instead of like Ray lose or hyperbolic
tangents and so on so it turns out that
if you initialize these very carefully
those can be made to capture these
signals very very well so that's the
kind of high-level overview and we'll go
through the paper in a bit of a fashion
of someone that is not in this
particular literature so this is not
going to be like as in-depth or
technical as usually because I myself am
NOT super familiar with with this kind
of literature with the neural
representations and so on so if you go
at this paper from a machine learning
perspective the first like you're going
to be ultimately like super confused at
the beginning so I'm going to try to
kind of clear up read retrace my steps
of my confusion okay so I love that this
paper starts out we're interested in a
class of functions Phi that satisfy
equations of the form this right here
they aren't we all like your a we are
interested in a class of functions okay
I've never you know particularly had
many dreams about functions like this
but so how can you how can you look at
this so we're interested in the relation
between inputs and outputs this here is
the function as you can see this maps
input to output okay and we're also
interested in its derivatives so here
you go first second third derivative and
so on so this function right here is
what we're going to call a neural
representation or an implicit
representation it's called a neural
representation I guess if it's a neural
network that this function is so so far
so good you've seen this right you've
seen this could be a data point and then
could map it to a label or something
like this since we're going to represent
images you already know maybe against a
generative adversarial Network where
this here is the latent vector and then
you have a neural network mapping this
latent vector to an image right so this
is going to produce an image this here
is quite similar but not quite so in
again I guess this here would count as
the the representation the continuous
representation of this picture however
in this case right here the function
itself is the representation so in again
what we do we learn this right here this
function Phi we learn this from data
such that if I plug in one particular
vector I get one particular image and if
I plug in another vector I get another
image and the function always stays the
same here it's going to be one function
per image so each
image the function is the image so how
is a function at image you can simply if
I have an image and it's made of pixels
right so it's made of pixels each pixel
has an X and the y coordinate okay let's
call that X 1 and X 2 the coordinate of
that and each pixel also has a color
value right which is three-dimensional
so each pixel has a three-dimensional or
G be color value so technically an image
is a function from coordinates to pixel
values okay so if even if this is my
image is represented by a function then
if I input any coordinates like 3 for
that function should return what are the
RGB values at that maybe it's like 0.5
0.7 and 0.1 those are the RGB values at
that okay so now the goal is to have
this right here be a neural network
where I have like a multi-layer
perceptron and they I think they always
use like a five layer MLPs so really
simple neural networks and you simply
input so here you have two input neurons
where this here goes so one gets the
three one gets the four then this
travels through the network and at the
end the network should output three
output nodes and they should be like the
point five point seven point one okay
now again this network here is they now
train this network to map input to
output okay to map coordinates to values
and this of course it is one particular
image so you're gonna have one neural
network per image now you might
reasonably ask why why do we do it like
this right why don't we just save the
image as the pixel values why do we need
like a function mapping the coordinates
to the pixels and that's a valid
yes and the image is just one example of
this but one advantage that you
immediately get is that now you have a
continuous representation so now you
cannot not only do you know because if
you store an image like this you only
know its value at each of the pixel
locations however if you store an image
like this you know its value at any
continuous in-between location right
so you can ask the network what's the
pixel value at three point two and four
point one alright it will give you an
answer and if the network is trained
well it will give you sort of a an
answer that makes sense that is what's
the exact color at this sub pixel
location right here now so far so good
right so essentially this boils down to
not really a machine learning problem in
the classic sense but an optimization
problem because all you have to do is
you have to make the neural network
match all input to all output there's
not really a training and a test set
right here namely your data set is going
to be all the pixels in the image so
each pixel in the image is going to be
one data point because it's one so each
pixel is XY to RGB okay and the way they
train these networks you know at the
examples of pixels the way they train it
they simply sample a mini batch of
pixels like this one this one this one
this one this one they use that mini
batch to train the network to do one
step to train the network and then they
sample another mini batch and so on you
might sample the same pixels multiple
times but ultimately what you want is
sort of a continuous representation of
the image that there this is not a new
idea and this has been around and they
cite a lot of literature where this has
been around before so what their new
thing is is that they say these other
representations so if you use a neural
network in a classic sense like this
and you do your training with the mini
matches like this what you'll end up
with is a bad image so if you then if
you then simply go right once you've
trained the network you can take it and
take your network and you can simply
output each pixel location so you say
okay now I'm going to reproduce this
image using my network because if it's
trained well it certainly give me back
the positions at the pixels so you ask
it what 0 0
what's 0 1 what's 0 2 that's 0 at 0 3
and you can fill in the picture and that
usually gives you very bad outcomes or
so they claim I mean I haven't checked
it particularly but you can see right
here this is the ground truth and the
here you have a network that is
parameterised with rayleigh functions
like with relu nonlinearities and as you
can see the Rayleigh network misses a
lot of the sort of higher definition
things in the image and so it depends on
the architecture that you use how well
you can make a neural network represent
those things again you kind of need to
forget what you what you know about
machine learning in the classic sense
because like I'd still see people you're
gonna go just use again or something
like this so yes valid point but we're
in the business right now of of solving
this particular problem and as we'll go
on to see it's not just about images but
images are a nice example of a natural
signal so the 10h networks you also see
they I think they fail even harder they
have these artifacts back here even and
this here it gets better when you do
Rayleigh networks with what is called a
positional encoding so not only do you
have your X and your Y coordinates go
through a rare loot Network but you also
have them go through a positional
encoding and that's very much like in
like you would have in a transfer
so if you watch my video about attention
is all you need
I explained how the positional encodings
work there but basically what you do is
you map these things to cosine and sine
waves so you're going to be like it's
the sine of X times 10 and then the sine
wave of x times a hundred and so on so
which you'll end up and you do the same
for Y and that ends you up with more
features that sort of then the function
can use to represent positions way
better than just given the x and y
coordinates if you do that you kind of
recover some of the image but you see
here they also analyze how so this is
the ground truth and this is the
gradient of the ground truth which is
basically a a sobel filter if you know
that it's basically an edge detector
color gradient thing and then this here
is the second derivative the laplacian
of the image and ideally if your
implicit representation models the
signal very well it should also model
the derivatives of the signal very well
so now we're kind of connecting it to
what we saw at the beginning right these
siren networks are specifically designed
to not only match the signal right here
but also match its derivatives and if
you match maybe in an image it's not so
it's not that important to match the
derivatives even though it is because
there are small things like you can see
right here the grass isn't as well
represented and here you mostly you get
some artifacts that you see here in the
in the gradient might not be as
important for images in terms of human
vision but for many signals it's also
important to match the derivatives and
here at the siren even though it's
trained on the image itself you can see
that it's
derivatives are very much in line with
the original signal so simply by
matching the signal you this
architecture manages to also capture the
derivatives of the signal and therefore
have a more faithful representation
okay so that was positional RBF ray lose
are simply the rail network and I think
somewhere in here there is an RBF kernel
if you young kids don't know what an RBF
kernel is then ya know I guess I guess I
don't want to I don't want to dunk on
anyone it's basically you how do I
explain him you map it to an infinite
dimensional space using Gaussian kernels
yeah maybe Wikipedia is better at that
than I am
so sirens what what do they do in order
to be able to capture a signal very well
what do how do how does it sing a siren
different from like an RBF Network and
the answer is pretty pretty pretty
simple so the architecture of a siren
network is the end does it all already
stand for network I'm not sure honestly
maybe we'll find out
[Music]
yes it's the sinusoidal representation
networks so the N is networks so we
don't say siren Network we say siren and
a siren is simply made of what is that
here it's a multi-layer perceptron
basically right so it is a this here is
the network the network this is the
final layer of the network which is a
linear layer before that you have all
these layers just not concatenated but
following each other so it's a
multi-layer perceptron pretty regular
and each of the layers in the
multi-layer perceptron is made up like
this you have an input you multiplied by
a weight matrix you add a bias and then
you put it through a sine wave so the
sine wave here is really that's that's
the only change from a multi-format
MLP otherwise so usually here you have
something like a sigmoid or a rayleigh
function now you have a sine wave and
the I mean it's a bit weird right
because a function is like this
so it has this Center thing where it
kind of switches but here it's linear
and monotonic and here it's kind of
constant and even a even a sigmoid so
the sigmoid is don't remember like this
yes I guess so the sigmoid is like this
so it's kind of constant here constant
here monotonic and so on we're used to
monotonic activation functions where as
a sine wave is really different the sine
wave of course is something like this
right where it's not monotonic at all
like if you if you want to increase your
function value at any point and you're
here and you go up the hill and you do a
step that's too large you end up down
the hill again but it turns out that
these these networks have particularly
have some good properties if you want to
capture natural signals and they have
some bad properties namely that the fact
that they are periodic and go down again
and the reason why they get around the
bad properties is because or so they
claim they initialize the network in a
very particular fashion because I think
at least I when I when I started in deep
learning I had this idea so a lot of
other people must have had this idea too
of like hey what if I just replaced a
non-linearity with like a sine function
could I do something this and then tried
it out and it didn't really work so I
scrapped that now this here of course
isn't simply replacing than this
Network it's also using the neural
network for something completely
different than I would namely it's using
the neural network to learn these
implicit representations and not like I
would to do simply for learning a data
set but still it seems like you need to
initialize them fairly with with very
careful consideration and we'll go on on
to that right now so actually they just
described it it's it's not like a it's
not very interesting but you need to
sample the weights uniformly from this
uniform distribution where I think yeah
and they have a proof in the
supplementary material where they sort
of show why that is so or not here we
propose to draw weights with C equals
six such that W is in this uniform
distribution right here oh no it's
different okay this ensures that the
input to each of the sign activation is
normal distributed with a standard
deviation of one since only a few
weights have magnitude larger than pi
the frequency throughout the sign
network grows only slowly finally we
propose to initialize the first layer of
the sine network with weights so that
the sine function spans multiple periods
over negative 1 to 1
we found w0 to equal 30 to work well for
all the applications in this work the
proposed initialization scheme yielded
fast and robust conversions using the
atom optimizer for all experiments in
this work so the initialization here
takes a fairly prominent piece in that
paper which tells me maybe that they
have spent a lot of time working on this
and this is I mean if this is the case
this is to their credit because I guess
most people like me would try out
something like this and then after a
while realize it doesn't work and to you
know be so convinced and to go and
really figure out how do we need to
initialize these to make it work
and of course as you're doing this
there's still like a 99% chance that
it's not going to work once you've done
that is quite respectable I find it
might have been really different this
might have been the first thing they
thought about and just worked it out but
yeah okay so what what is the deal with
all these derivatives now since this
network right here has these sine waves
in it right so it's a neural network
with sine waves as derivatives as
nonlinearities what now so we have a
neural network what now is the first
derivative of that neural network right
with respect to its input so we have an
input now what's the first derivative
with respect to its input and the cool
thing about this is what's the first
derivative of a sine wave
it's of course a sine wave that's
shifted so it's a cosine which is a sine
wave
that's simply phase shifted and then the
next derivative again is a shifted sine
wave and so on so the derivative of a
siren is a siren and that does not hold
for any of these other nonlinearities so
in Ray lose it's the derivative of a
rail network is like a con so if we if I
take the derivative of this it's like a
constant zero right here and then a
constant one right here and if I then
take the derivative again it's simply a
constant zero function right and all
these other nonlinearities their
derivatives are different from
themselves and here since we want to not
only match a signal but also the signals
derivatives these property of this siren
become in very very very handy so how do
you train a siren we've already alluded
to how you would do that in the in the
kind of idea of matching an image where
you simply train the pixel values to the
RGB values but there's more that you can
do with the sirens given
that they basically given that their
derivatives are also sirens what you can
do so with the image part we've
basically neglected all of this we
simply said we want to find a
relationship between the input X and the
output like this what we can also do is
we can say no no we want to find a
relationship between the input and its
first derivative and not even have this
as part of the let's say of the loss
function and then we can see what comes
out so that's what they do
oh can I find it can I find it that's
what they do right here okay so here you
see the the ground truth image and this
is its gradient and this is its
laplacian okay now we've already seen
that we can fit the image itself but
what if we just fit the first derivative
so we simply input this thing right here
we input this into the siren we do the
same thing right the siren is now it
maps x and y to our GB but our loss
function isn't going to be mapping x and
y to RGB our loss function is going to
to depend on the gradient of that so our
loss function is going to be something
like the gradient of the image that's
called the image I minus the gradient of
that function that map's X of this
function right here okay because we have
these auto differentiation tools right
now we can easily make this into a loss
function so here we are looking for the
function whose gradient matches the
gradient of the image right now again
you can say
why is this why can't we just match the
image itself and I validate
it's not about why can't we just it's
about demonstrating the power of these
networks so if you only match the
gradients right what you'll find is if
you then look at the function right you
still find the function you don't you
don't find the gradient you still train
the function you still train the weights
of the function itself but the loss
function depends on the gradient of that
function if you do that you'll find that
if you then look at the function again
you can ask the function to produce the
image by simply cycling over each of the
coordinates you'll find that look at
that just by matching the gradient
you'll match the image itself pretty
pretty well right and that's pretty cool
um now of course you're not going to
match the RGB values this is a grayscale
image and you know there's a there's
kind of a reason for that because since
the the gradient losses like constant
bias information so what if you'd match
an RGB image I'm gonna guess you're
going to have like a color very much
color distortions but and here what
you're going to have in this case is
just distortions in luminosity like if
you know that if you have a function if
you have the derivative of a function
and you want to find the function itself
and you integrate then the solution is
always an entire space of functions
because you will integrate the function
this thing right here and so with the
whatever its input is and you have to
add a constant and you don't know what
the constant was in the original
function because when you derive the
function the constant drops away so
similarly here what we'd expect is that
the image that we're getting back will
be faithful with respect to like it's
it's
borders right since we're matching the
gradient and the gradient is basically
an edge detector will match the sort of
edge information of the picture which
you can clearly see but what we would
expect is some difference in overall
luminosity and I don't even know how
they exactly did this because they now
have to choose a constant to add maybe
they just chose it in some way or maybe
they just let the network do but this is
you know still pretty pretty impressive
you can see there's some detail missing
but not much and the same exact same
thing you can do for matching the second
derivative so now you match the
laplacian of the image and remember in
the rail networks they don't even have a
laplacian it's a constant so this is
something you could never do and you can
see that the outcoming image is still
pretty good right this or this is now
missing the constant luminosity in the
first and second derivative sorry in the
in the 0s and first derivative and still
the information is the the
reconstruction is pretty good all right
so these demonstrates kind of the power
of these networks again we're not having
our data set our entire data set is just
this image so if we fit something then
this thing right here is our entire data
set there's no there's no big data set
and this is a test sample like this is
the data set and the test sample at the
same I guess you can consider the
laplacian here the data set and then the
actual image is the test sample like the
label or something like this so what
does that buy you here is a thing you
can do if you want to mix two images
what do you do so if you want to mix
this and this what you could do is
linearly interpolate but that would be
not very cool because right here you
have a lot of like very bright pixels
which probably have like values of 1 and
here you'd have the dark pixels which
probably have values like more or close
to zero and the if you simply mix them
if you simply add them together
/ - then you'd get kind of get a wash of
the two and similarly here you kind of
wash out the bear because you'd have
some pixel values here that would come
over and generally not not a good idea
to mix images like this now you know
with Ganz we can do this but we have to
have like a training data set and so on
here what we'll say is we'll simply say
we'll take the gradient of this and
we'll take the gradient of this and then
we'll add the two gradient maps now what
does thus is that as you can see right
here on the left is the composite
gradients and what this does is right
here in the sky there is no gradient
information in this image because it's
just a flat patch of sky right so and
down maybe down here there's not that
much gradient information there is a bit
right but not here so that's where this
bear head is and if you want to mix
images like it can be a good idea to mix
their gradients because generally the
information in an image is where the
gradients are so what we would expect
the gradient to represent the gradient
would carry over this portion it would
maybe carry over a bit of this portion
it would carry over this portion and
this portion so everything where the
signal is not flat so here you can see
the composite gradient and if we fit
again we fit our function such that the
gradient of the function that we fit
matches this mixed gradient right here
then this is the gradient of the
function that we match and this is the
actual function and you can see pretty
pretty good right
it basically mixed everywhere where
there was gradient and this is now just
reconstructed from this gradient there
is no I think there is no at least as I
understand it there is no pixel
information carried over from either of
those images they are simply added to
this gradient
the gradient is fit and then the
function is asked to output pixel value
at each location and that's that okay so
this is just a you know thing that you
can play around with but they do they do
other more interesting things right here
for example this representing shapes
with signed distance functions so if you
go over the formulation the actual
formulation of their loss function we
haven't actually done this right quite
yet it's here it's very complicated Lee
stated but ultimately what this means is
so a component right here is are these
CM which are constraints so this loss
function operates on these constraints
and the constraints are across a of X
which basically is just X it's kind of a
the anything depending on the input
itself then the output of the function
the gradient of the output of the
function the second derivative third
derivative and so on so this these
sirens can fit anything that you can
formulate as a set of constraints that
relate the input of the function right
here to its output or any of its
derivatives and we've already seen that
at once we if we fit an image our only
constraint is that these things match
right here with the original image that
the coordinates are mapped to the RGB
values then when we match the gradients
we don't care about this we only care
about the relation between this and so
on so the loss function is literally
just over the entire signal space which
in our case was was over the entire
image we want these constraints to hold
or to be as small as possible or the
constraints are always formulate such
that if they are fulfilled they equal
zero and so the for exam
the l2 loss between the RGB values of
the true image and the RGB values that
you fit the RGB loss sorry the l2 loss
would be a constraint like this and of
course the more differentiable you make
it the more the easier this network has
at fitting it right so that's why there
is this norm right here but it's not
that complicated it simply says whatever
you can formulate as a constraint on
relating the inputs to the outputs or
any of the derivatives of this implicit
representation that is the loss function
alright so the in the next interesting
thing we can do as I said is
representing shapes with signed distance
functions so we're going to go slowly
and this is yeah it's not that hard
inspired by recent work on shape
representation with differentiable
signed distance functions as DFS we fit
s DFS directly on oriented point clouds
using both Rayleigh based implicit
neural representations and sirens ok so
what is an S DFA signed distance
function that's pretty easy a signed
distance function is simply a distance
function with a sign like wow so a a if
you have a and it's usually done if you
have like a boundary somewhere between
things then of course any point here has
a distance to the boundary but you if
you have a signed distance function it
simply means that each point also has a
sign in front of it and that means all
the things on one side of the boundary
maybe have a plus and all the things on
the other side maybe have a minus so
even though two points could be the same
distance from the boundary one is like
plus five away and one is negative five
away and you can do this this is useful
for example when you fit point clouds as
they do in this example so when they
have point clouds
and that's usually in 3d space but if
you have point clouds you basically have
points right here and you know that the
points should represent some kind of
shape maybe a wall or so they have these
room interiors as you can see right here
so this is a 3d scene but you only have
a point cloud of the 3d scene and what
that means is that maybe you were in
this room and you put up a laser scanner
right here laser scanner I don't have no
clue how a laser scanner looks and the
laser scanner kind of shoots lasers at
random locations and always measures the
distance right and that's that's how you
end up with a point cloud so you'll end
up with like a point cloud where in 3d
space you know where the laser hit
something and the reasonable assumption
to make if you have like a dense
sampling of this is that you should be
able to like connect those point clouds
in some way to obtain the actual
continuous shape of the thing that you
measured and this is what we're going to
try to do with these sirens right to go
from point clouds to shape by training
and implicit representation so we're
going to train a neural network that
represents this shape right here
basically by mapping coordinates to two
signed distance values so whenever we
ask the neural network at this location
here
what's the signed distance and it's
going to tell us oh it's plus 5 or at at
this location here what's the scientist
and it's going to tell us oh it's zero
right so we're going to we're going to
train a neural network to do that and
hello yes No ok so this is a bit more
complicated and since we have these
awesome power of the sirens we can also
do two more constraints so we know
and this goes on this amounts to solving
a particular icono boundary value
problem that constrains the norm of
spatial gradients to be one almost
everywhere so this icon abound revalue
problem this is a property of signed
distance function that the norm of the
gradient with respect to the input is 1
almost everywhere almost everywhere
means everywhere I guess except at the
boundary itself where the distance is
zero so I could be wrong
note that rail networks are seeming
seemingly ideal for representing s DF s
as their gradients are a locally
constant and their second derivatives
are zero adequate training procedure for
working directly with point clouds were
described in Prior work we fit a siren
to an oriented point cloud using a loss
of the form and now we look at the loss
so the first thing you observe in the
loss is that it is made of three
different integrals and that simply
means they now partition the space right
here they partition it into two
different they partition it into two
different regions so to say so we go
here no can i zoom here
so the first region is going to be
whatever is on the boundary itself right
and that's basically wherever a point
whatever a point hit right whenever you
have a point or on the boundary itself
that's going to be your Omega zero is
going to be that and then all the other
points right here are going to be part
of your Omega without the Omega zero so
you're going to have different
constraints for all of these things
right here for example and I'm have to
pay attention that I don't say anything
wrong you will have this this constraint
of this gradient my tablet I mean maybe
I'll start monetizing just so I can get
a new tablet okay so
no okay the this this condition right
here says that the gradient should be
one and that's actually everywhere right
so I was wrong that the gradient is only
one outside the boundary then you can
see right here the last part is all the
points that are not on the boundary
since right our network Maps any point
in 3d space to assign distance function
so most of these points aren't going to
be on the boundary itself even though in
the mini-batch where we train where they
train the sample points on and off the
on and off the boundary at the at equal
rates just to to have the network train
more stable so this is a condition on
all the points off of the boundary and
they say here this function is this
exponential function with alpha larger
than one it penalizes off surface points
for creating SDF value is close to zero
so this is simply a regularizer
that says whenever i input coordinates
that are far away from the boundary from
the surface then there should be a large
signed distance function like it should
not be close to zero because it's away
from a boundary okay and in practice how
you're gonna train this is if you have a
point cloud if your coordinates are far
away from the next point then this this
is going to be a high this should be a
high value otherwise the network is
penalized so we have this condition
right here on the gradients which we
know signed distance function should
fulfill we have this thing right here
which is a regularizer basically telling
points far away from our data that they
should have a high distance function and
then we have this last thing right here
which is for all the points on the
surface itself here's what we'll what we
require first of all we require there
you to be zero or close to zero right
this is the lost functions that we want
to minimize this and this is simply the
output value so the signed distance
function of points on the surface you
know the things we actually measure they
should be zero
right because the signed distance
function measures how far away from the
surface you are so this is pretty
intuitive but then also this right here
it says that the gradient of the signed
distance function and the normal vector
of that point should align and that
basically means and this is now I think
this is because we have an oriented
point cloud or no yes so what we can do
is we can kind of connect points next to
each other and then calculate the normal
vectors of that right and the signed did
the network if we ask the network hey
what do you think about this position
right here the network should tell us
first of all the signed distance
function should be zero because it's on
the boundary
second of all the norm of the gradient
of the signed distance function at that
point
should be one because that's a property
of signed distance function and third
and that's the thing right now the
gradient of the signed distance function
should align with this normal vector
right and that's you know pretty
intuitive because you want you want the
signed distance function to increase in
value the gradient basically tells you
where the highest increase in value of
the function is you want it to increase
along the normal direction and not along
any other direction so that's a pretty
good pretty good constraint to have so
you can see right here I mean you don't
really have to understand exactly about
signed distance functions and so on but
these sirens are pretty good at
capturing all of these different
constraints and this was a point you
know on the surface points off the
surface additionally say hey you should
have a pretty high valley
and actually not zero value but a pretty
high value so and again we only fit one
particular scene we only ever fit one
scene with an entire network so the
entire neural network did this this in
this whole structure right here
everything is captured by this neural
network that we trained on the point
cloud and you can see that if you use a
ray loo what you'll get is this super
super wobbly because if even if you
train the rail you with the same loss
function these constraints on the
gradients they're just not gonna work
out with the relu because the gradients
are like constant and discontinuous
right whereas the siren can basically
fulfill all of these constraints on the
different parts like on the values and
on the gradients of that of the loss
function and they have another example
right here where they fit this shape
yeah so you see all that the details are
preserved way better where the Ray lose
they'll simply kind of flatten over
everything and make it wobbly alright so
I hope this sort of made sense and we'll
go to the last thing right now
but is restarting I want to show you the
website right here they have for this
it's a pretty cool website to go along
with it
and as you can see right here they have
all these samples that they have in the
paper but also in animated format in as
you can see right here this is the
fitting process the learning process of
how you represent these images so as I
said there you want to fit these
functions to the ground truth and that
happens in steps so this is very much
like you would learn a deep learning
functions that I think they use the atom
optimizer it's just that the data set
now come all comes from this one ground
truth image and you can see that the
siren Network on the right pretty
quickly zeroes in on the on the image
and then gets the details subsequently
right they also represent audio with
this and you can watch that they
represent video
compare that to Ray Lu representations
then here solving the Poisson equation
is where you only fit the gradients or
the laplacian of an image and still get
out the good image that's pretty cool
and here you can see that you can
actually play around with these things
so you can click on them and look at
this look at this learned thing so on
the left you can see what the siren
Network learned and I must scroll down
here a bit and on the right is a ray Lu
representation of the same thing so this
is the same network with the same
objective
it just has Ray Lewis instead of sine
waves as activation functions so you can
see how much of a difference that makes
right here and the middle is array with
the positional encodings still not good
right the only the only thing right here
that you have to think of if you look at
how big these sirens are how many
parameters they have they're about at
the order of magnitude of how many
pixels there are in the image so I'm
yeah it's certainly a
method but - like these it's not like
your the implicit representation here is
very very well at generalizing though it
would be very cool to see what happens
outside right if you because now you
have you can input any XY coordinates so
technically you'd you could continue the
picture to the bottom and just see what
the siren thinks should be here at the
bottom so all of these things would be
pretty pretty cool to actually
experiment with and they have the code
available to do that and you can see the
feeding process of the Helmholtz
equation right here and related projects
a pretty cool website I definitely value
to check it out and let's go back to the
paper and we're back and my tablet
crashed and let's continue so they're
now going on to use sirens in order to
solve PD es and so in physics often you
have these problems where you are given
an equation but the equation doesn't
necessarily involve a function itself
but only involves derivatives of that
function like or relates derivatives to
the function and so on so one example
here is this Helmholtz equation that's
given as this where the I think the the
F is a known function but this is the
wave field we want to you want to get
you want to figure out which is unknown
and then this H M is including for
example this right here which is the
Laplace operator so you're given the
relation between the function and a
Laplace operator of the wave that you
want to find out and your task is to
recover the wave now I don't want to go
very much into this right here but what
you can do is basically you can measure
you can have a room and you can have
measurements of the way four of its
derivatives and so on and then you kind
of calculate backwards from the
measurements to what the actual wave was
and these sirens turn out to
be very very good at things like this
and I guess that's in this solving for
the wave field things but essentially
what this amounts to is a numerical salt
and numerical solution of these partial
differential equations in physics using
these sirens and that's pretty cool and
the last thing they do is and this gets
back to a more of the machine learning
context where they say learning a space
of implicit functions so now they go
ahead and say yeah so we can represent
images in terms of these of these
functions right but each image is
basically its own function so each image
is basically an optimization a fitting
problem can we somehow learn functions
of functions so this goes this comes now
back to more of a machine learning
context where you say so I I have a
network right here that I have a network
that gives me the parameters of the
siren so this right here is okay let's
let's go to an example in this example
what you'll have is you have an image
like this one where a few pixels are
masked actually most of the pixels are
masked and you want to put this into a
CNN and the CNN should output the
parameters of the siren network so the
parameters because the the siren network
given its parameters is the image itself
so that's the siren a set siren Network
the siren is the image if you know its
parameters right so here you train a CNN
to give you the parameters of the siren
that's almost the same
as training a CNN to give you the image
directly but again we don't want to have
the explicit representation of an image
we want to have the implicit
representation such that it's continuous
and we can manipulate it and so on so
the CNN is now trained on a data set so
you take C 410 and you construct a whole
bunch of of images with only kind of a
hundred pixels remaining and then you
train a CNN to give you the parameters
of the siren that would reconstruct the
ground truth right and then you can test
that on the test image and you can see
right here the results are pretty good
so these are test samples these are now
these are now images that were not seen
during training of this CNN and
therefore the outcoming
siren also hasn't seen that image it's
the siren is simply parameterised by the
CNN you can see this works pretty well
so even if you don't have ten pixels you
already get something out of it right
and if you have a hundred pixel you
already get fairly close to the to the
ground truth right here now this is not
gam quality images of course but it's
pretty impressive to see that an
implicit parameterization an implicit
representation of the images can be so
powerful right yeah so this this is a
pretty cool thing and again it's it's
better than its it's kind of more back
to the machine learning framework that
you're used to because there's a train
and the test data set and now the only
thing is that the output is a function
given by its parameters and not the
actual pixel values okay so that's
actually let's look at the broader
impact statement the proposed siren
representation enables accurate
representations of natural signals such
as images audio and video in a deep
learning framework this may be an
enabler for downstream tasks involve
such signals such as classification for
images or speech-to-text systems for
audio such applications may be leveraged
for both positive and negative ends
Saturn may in the future further enable
novel approaches to the generation of
such signals this has potential for
misuse in impersonating actors without
their consent for an in-depth discussion
of so-called deep fakes we refer the
reader to a recent review article in her
neural rendering this has this has like
no perplexity like no perplexity at all
like is anyone benefited by this
seriously okay but at least we made the
authors think of the consequences of
their research yeah so I invite you to
check out this paper maybe with this
right now you can follow a bit better
what happens here this is a different
paradigm of research it's a cool
paradigm it's a way from your usual
machine learning framework and yeah so
I'm excited what happens next in this I
also invite you to check out the
websites they have lots of videos and
goodies and so on and with that bye bye